the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones season
8 video in this video i want to do
something a little different i want to
give my thoughts about why i think the
night king was afraid to fight jon snow
during the long night battle at
winterfell at first this answer might
seem kinda obvious when you think about
it however in order for this to actually
work we will have to go back a few
seasons when we all thought everything
in game of thrones had some sort of
meaning to it now we all remember how
game of thrones ended at least for some
of us it kind of seemed like a lot of
things were meaningless in the end
however it wasn't always like this back
when i first started making game of
thrones videos around season 6 and
season 7 it seemed like every single
scene had some sort of significance and
in one way or another it would have an
effect on the ending i don't know about
all of you but this was when the game of
thrones fandom was the most fun
my absolute favorite thing about game of
thrones was all the different theories
surrounding it back then it honestly
seemed like there was an endless amount
of ways this show could have actually
ended unfortunately as we all know a lot
of those ideas fizzled out by the final
season once we saw the direction the
game of thrones writers david and dan
were heading in
now even with that in mind i still want
to do something a little different with
this video like i said at the beginning
if we go back only a few seasons when we
all thought every scene in game of
thrones had meaning i think we might be
able to see why the night king was
afraid to fight jon snow in the end but
like i said this idea will only work if
we look at the show through that lens i
think the reason why the night king did
not want to fight jon snow one versus
one was because of what he saw john do
back at heart home now if you remember
when jon snow defeated his first white
walker the night king was actually
watching jon when that happened not only
was the night king watching but judging
by the look on his face it seemed like
he knew there was something very special
about jon snow or at the very least he
knew there was something very special
about jon snow's sword then when the
night king finally saw jon snow again
during the long night battle for
winterfell he did not forget what he saw
him do back at heart home
so maybe just maybe he knew jon snow
would do the same exact thing to him if
he engaged him in a one versus one sword
fight this and honestly only this is the
only way i can justify the night king
not wanting to fight jon snow in the end
i mean let's be honest it would have
been really stupid for the night king to
fight jon if he knew he was vulnerable
to valyrian steel like the other white
walkers were not only would this explain
why the night king avoided fighting him
but it would also give more significance
to the scene when the night king was
looking on as jon snow defeated the
white walker at harthome again we all
know most of the foreshadowing went
right out of the window like brain stark
by the final season but i think this
does make some sense of that scene let
me know what all of you think down below
does this work for you or do you still
think that scene made no sense
whatsoever believe me i will not be mad
if you think it was dumb no one was more
upset than i was when the night king
died before fighting jon snow and if you
know you know this isn't even the most
upsetting thing about this what makes
jon snow not fighting the night king
even worse is the fact that the actor
who was the night king is arguably one
of the most badass fight choreographers
in all of hollywood the man has been
showing actors most notably he showed
all the game of thrones actors how to
fight with a sword he had been doing
this for over 30 years as a matter of
fact he was the stand-in for all the sir
arthur dane fight scenes now the actor
who was standing right here acting like
he was sir arthur dain was not the same
man who did the sword fighting once his
helmet hit his face the man who was
fighting with a sword in each hand was
the same guy who was the night king so
just imagine how amazing the fight
scenes could have been if only jon snow
was allowed to fight the night king
before the show ended i mean how can you
give the night king this awesome magical
ice sword and have a 30-year veteran
stunt coordinator as the night king yet
not let him use that in the final season
during the biggest battle we had all
been waiting for since literally the
opening scene of the opening episode now
i could go on and on about this for days
but i won't do that because it will only
make me even more upset when i think
about it the only way i can stop myself
from being mad about this is if i give
these scenes some sort of meaning by
telling myself the night king was too
afraid to fight jon snow because of what
he saw at heart home then again maybe
i'm just making excuses
as always let me know what all of you
think leave your thoughts down below i
will be reading them once this video
goes live
i want to thank all of you once again
for watching my videos i hope everyone
has a great day i will see you soon in
the next one bye
so
[Music]
you